[Applaudissements]
les cougars peuvent rougir de plaisir
ils viennent de se qualifier pour la
finale du championnat de France de
première division une victoire acquise
au bout du suspense contre les Templiers
de Sénart mené des victoires à une des
joueurs de Montigny-le-Bretonneux en
suranversé la tendance ce dimanche 3
septembre en remportant les deux matchs
c'est pas facile à en finir en dixième
manche avec un point d'avance quoi on
pensait pouvoir faire ça un peu plus
rapidement mais au fait ils nous ont
quand même donné du fil à retordre et
c'était pas évident ici ils ont été ils
ont été assez bons pendant le week-end
donc non pas facile une demi-finale pas
facile quoi mais bon au final c'est nous
qui gagnons cette finale de première
division de baseball sera la deuxième de
l'histoire des Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux après 2018 pour
le club c'est très très historique c'est
un club que moi quand j'ai commencé je
viens plus d'ici je viens de dupuc du
prix et à l'époque ils avaient zéro
victoire et là maintenant on gagne un
championnat à challenge et on est en
finale du championnat et on va en Coupe
d'Europe l'année prochaine grâce à ça
les joueurs ils montent un jour ou
contre les Barracuda de Montpellier
l'équipe du sud de la France a terminé
première de l'autre poule du championnat
de France de D1 et non c'est une grosse
équipe ça va être compliqué ça va être
compliqué ça va être aussi dur
qu'aujourd'hui mais on a nos chances
c'est c'est comme tout dans le sport je
veux dire là c'est pas sans qu'on n'a
pas joué tant que la dernière balle n'a
pas été lancée tout peut arriver et du
coup on y va pour aller gagner la finale
les cougars devront vite se remettre de
leurs émotions pour la grande finale
recevront Montpellier au stade Jean
maréchal ce samedi 9 et dimanche 17
septembre les Yvelinois joueront le
weekend suivant à l'extérieur il faudra
trois victoires aux animaux pour
soulever la coupe
oh dommage
[Applaudissements]